in life Michael Gibson was a registrar
recording the births deaths and
marriages of others when he passed away
in early April his own cause of death
was documented as probable kovat 19 his
daughter Kathy says the implication of
government policies which saw untested
kovat patients sent into care homes must
now be examined I think the government
guidance that hospitals implemented to
discharge people as rapidly as possible
to care homes full of vulnerable people
was incredibly irresponsible I think it
was an unbelievable act and they need to
be held to account for that who do you
hold responsible for this policy
it's got HM government on the top of it
whoever wrote it originally whoever
edited it and whoever signed it off for
publication must be held responsible for
the consequences Michael Gibson was a
resident at the Chur Woodhouse care
center in Oxfordshire a place which
Kathy says looked after her father with
great kindness this is what we've pieced
together about the circumstances
surrounding his death Kathy says staff
told her a kovat patient was discharged
back to the home in mid-march I
understand the home felt pressured to
take the resident back and was told the
patient hadn't had a temperature for 48
hours
Joe Woodhouse say they weren't given any
guarantees the patient wasn't still
infectious Joe Woodhouse says taking
backpack Ovid resident is one of several
possibilities which could have caused
the death of Michael Gibson Kathy
Gardner has a PhD in the airborne spread
of infection
she says the lack of testing means
she'll never know for sure how her
father died compounding the fact she
couldn't sit with him in his final hours
we did drive up and were able to go and
see him through the window that night on
the Thursday night which was just
appalling ly sad it's not it's not what
I wanted to do
at that time but he died the next night
and it's very difficult to talk about
that still the Equality and Human Rights
Commission has said it's deeply
concerned by potential breaches in the
human rights of the elderly during the
pandemic and is urging the government to
acknowledge that the reality is that if
that doesn't happen we'll have to look
very carefully at how we exercise our
legal powers to ensure that governments
and local authorities are actually
meeting their obligations we've raised
Cathy gardener's concerns with the
Department of Health and Social Care and
await a response the government's
strategy has been to protect the NHS
from being overwhelmed and save lives
but at what cost to Britain's elderly in
care homes Lisa Holland Sky News